Good morning Hank, it's Friday, it's question
Friday, the day that I answer real questions
from real nerdfighters.
Are there any words you still can't spell?
I occasionally struggle with occasionally.
Also refrigerator, where is your "D" refrigerator?
Did you see that NASA tweeted Hank's video?
Yes I did! Hank, I'm glad you're not quite
as obsessed with space as you were when you
were 16, because that might have made your
brain explode.
Wait in Hank's video he said that telescope
can see into the past. How can you see into
the past?
Okay so light travels at a speed, so if something
is 13 billion light-years away, what we see
when we look at it happened 13 billion years
ago because that's how long it took the light
to get to us. Similarly, our sun is like 8
light-minutes away from us so we have no idea
what is currently happening on the sun. All
of our sun-related news is at least 8 minutes
old. Which is why the sun needs a twitter,
Hank. That wouldn't work? Bummer.
Which part of Will Grayson, Will Grayson did
you write?
Uppercase Will AKA straight Will AKA Schrödinger's
Will.
Hey do y'all fill up power steering fluid?
Sorry that was my question for Jiffy Lube.
Who the eff is Hank?
Hank is a comic book superhero from the DC
Universe who first appeared in 1939. Hank
is also known as "The Caped Crusader" and
"The Hank."
Where should I invest a small amount of money?
I recommend a broad index fund like the Wilshire
5000.
If you could live in any period of history,
which would it be?
This one. Why would anyone wanna live in a
period other than this one? Like I acknowledge
that Rome was fantastic and everything but
a nerd with 4 days on his hand can recreate
Rome in its entirety in Minecraft.
What are those blue creatures behind you?
There are blue creatures behind me? Do they
look menacing? You can't answer you're inside
the internet. I'm just gonna have to turn
around and face the music. Oh those guys?!
These were sewn for me by a nerdfighter. Possibly
they were supposed to be a present for Henry,
but anyway I took them.
Peeta or Gale?
I am with the bakers!
Do you use hair product?
No. The puff needs hair product like Hank
needs caffeine.
What's your overall stance on the Israeli/Palestinian
conflict?
My overall stance is that both sides need
to recognize the legitimacy of the other's
narrative.
Will your zombie novella ever be published?
It was released under a creative commons license
so it is freely available all over the internet
- link in the dooblydoo. However, before
you download it you are ethically obligated
to leave a comment thanking all the people
who donated because without them this terrible
zombie novella would not exist. Also you have
to promise to read one of my actual books
- link in the dooblydoo - so you don't believe
that I'm as bad a writer as my zombie novella
would indicate.
Why do we have eyelids?
I don't know; blinking is for COWARDS.
When you and Hank play clue, who is Mr. Green?
So Hank in the original British Cluedo, Mr.
Green is called Reverend Green but when they
brought it to America they felt like that
was sacrilege - sacrilege, by the way, is
another word I have trouble spelling. So they
renamed him Mr. Green, but anyway I'm usually
Colonel Mustard.
What English word retains its pronunciation
even after you take away 4 of its 5 letters?
Queue. Another word I have trouble spelling.
This is like the John Green Spelling Bee Nightmare
Edition of Question Friday.
What's your bracelet?
It's an Esther bracelet! You don't have an
Esther bracelet? You should get one, they
make the world suck less! Link in the dooblydoo.
Why was Henry crying at the end of your last
video?
That is not a question that was asked by a
parent. There is no "why." Like pretty much
the only two thoughts babies ever have are
"I am ecstatically happy," and "this could
be better." And they really only have one
strategy to take things from "this could be
better" to "I am ecstatically happy," which
is crying.
Why is a bubble round?
Because they're minimal surface structures,
and spheres have minimal surface.
How's your Warner Chilcott stock doing?
Thank you for asking, I'm down $32. Warner
Chilcott you need to do a better job of Warner
Chilcott-ing sick people or else I'm never
gonna get my money back.
Can I be your last question?
Almost.
Will you see Hank on Monday?
YES!
By the way, Hank, if you want an awesome gold
eagle shirt from our friend the Whomping Willow,
link in the dooblydoo.